- Wake up, taking over
your life right now,
I've got Gary Vee with me
- Hey.
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(intensifying instrumental)
(crowd screaming)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat melody)
You wanna help people
while you scratch your itch
for what you want to.
It's an important thing.
I think you'll get caught,
I highly recommend even
considering your circumstance,
my biggest Gary mentor piece of advice.
(girls laughing)
- [Woman] Please.
- You can help people
without making money.
- [Woman] Oh yeah.
- So I think it's super
important, like this is...
- [Woman] I have been.
- I get it but you
understand, the ambition to.
There's a lot of ways
to help people without
getting logos on your everything
and getting $15,000 a speech.
And it's an important
point. I'll tell you why.
It is the most important differentiator.
It's awesome and my
favorite part about you
is your entrepreneurial ambition.
You can aspire to fulfill
yourself and give back so much.
You can be a fucking ninja entrepreneur
fucking hardcore capitalist
and build fucking
the fucking biggest business in the world
and you can be an awesome person.
I wish we could get
everybody to win for yourself
and help others win too.
There's abundance out there.
You can win and they can win too
and there's people that talk
about like I'm gonna give
and there's other people
who are like I'm gonna win
and it's just like all convoluted.
It's both. It's fucking both.
(serene melody)
- [Man] Nah, I guess my question,
I do social marketing.
I do probably nothing
compared to what you do but,
I notice that it's like
a system you have to have
to get where you wanna get.
- Okay.
- [Man] So it's just creating that system
is the process it seems like.
- But the system's
remarkably individual, right?
Bro, there's no process.
There's your process.
You need to figure out you and
if you're the kind of person
that needs 11 hours of sleep
because that's your DNA,
then get your 11 hours of sleep
and dominate the other 13.
If you're the kind that needs an hour
for breakfast, lunch, and dinner,
and watch YouTube videos of like fucking
people climbing trees and
like that's how you roll,
then enjoy your three hours
of watching people climb trees
during your food consumption
hours and do you.
Like, I hate that people
try to be like me.
I have ridiculous,
over-the-top natural energy
that makes no sense to me and anybody else
that knows anything about me.
So like, don't wish on yourself.
Just figure out who the
fuck you are and do.
(serene melody)
- Today my only goal is to
inspire you to take on your day,
go to bed feeling amazing.
Wake up taking over your life right now.
I've got Gary Vee with me.
Which is, you know, to me up there with
the top dogs of inspiration, motivating.
Whether you wanna start a business,
whether you just wanna
feel better about yourself.
Gary is the man.
I know you guys always
say that I lift you up
but I brought in a little
extra support today.
So the only thing we're doing right now
for however long this video is
is our goal, our only
challenge is to lift them up.
- I think there's two
core things I think about
when I think about people feeling
like they're at their
lowest at a young age.
Number one.
Somehow you have to, and
maybe it's this video
or maybe it's something else,
realize you haven't even started living.
Perspective of age is imperative.
If you're 10, knowing
that you're gonna live
for another 100 years.
For a lot of logical brains they're like,
oh my god, wait a minute.
I have just started.
And even if the next
10 years are not great,
I still have my entire life.
Number two and this is
the big one. Gratitude.
I think one of the ways...
A lot of people are like,
Gary how have you helped so many people
get out of a low point?
I'm like by having them
focus on what's amazing.
I sit on the board of Charity Water.
When I really figured out that there are
tons, millions of people in Africa
walking seven miles for water, for this.
Literally, here it is.
For water, you start putting
things in perspective.
I just genuinely believe
that if you're even capable
of watching this vlog,
you're already in a very special place.
The likelihood, the odds of being born is
400 trillion to one.
400, you are more likely
to win the lottery
seven times in your life
than actually being born.
I want gratitude to become a pillar
of conversation in our society
because you have to be grateful,
you have to be grateful for what you have
instead of worrying about
what you don't have.
For every car, for money,
for fame, for jewelry.
For everything you don't have,
you have so much and my great grandma Anya
taught me a long time ago,
if you've got health, you've got wealth.
And everyday I'm so grateful
that the 11 people I love the most
were awake and born that day and alive
and not sick and not
terminally ill and didn't die.
And then so every business problem,
every skinned knee becomes so small
because I'm just so grateful for the thing
that actually matters.
And here's the analogy.
You know when you're driving
and the police lights go on
and you think you're
about to get pulled over
and then the cop drives past you
and you get so relieved
and then for five minutes
you've got both hands on
the steering wheel, right?
Like, you've got both
hands on the steering wheel
and all of a sudden you're like driving
the exact speed limit and
then 15 minutes later again
you're going 15 over
and you're one-handed.
That's how I think about this.
You have to stay grateful.
You can't take things for granted.
We have so much abundance in the world.
So much opportunity and
too many people are crying
about what they don't have instead of
being so deeply grateful
for what they have.
I'm so glad we did this.
- Dude, it's awesome, man.
- I will reach out anytime I'm...
- This is incredible, man.
- Dude, anytime you're in New York
and you need somewhere to
crash to work for a few minutes
in between or anything we can do.
Our house.
- I so appreciate that.
- I mean it.
Great to see you brother.
Take care of yourself and your fam.
- I would say keep it up
but I already know you will.
- You will as well, man. Take care.